hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy i'm kristen decervo the chief
learning officer at khan academy and i
am excited today to talk to dr matt
townsley who is a professor and author
of making grades matter
we'll be talking about all things
grading so if you have questions please
drop them into the chat
i want to remind you before we start
that khan academy is a non-profit
organization we're able to do our work
thanks to donations from folks like you
if you go to khan academy.org donate
you'll find a place where you can make
that donation and help us keep doing
that work so thank you so much for if
you're able to give
i also want to recognize our corporate
uh folks who have helped support us in
the times of covet including a t general
motors and fastly
next if you want to
listen to this broadcast again or find
previous broadcasts and have ways to
listen to those when you're at the gym
on your walk or otherwise listening to
audio you can find them at homeroom with
sal the podcast
we look forward to uh seeing you there
so as i said i'm excited today to
welcome matt tounsley he is the author
of making grades matter standards based
grading
in a secondary plc so i'm looking
forward to talking about all things
grading welcome
well hello thank you very much for
having me
absolutely so
i always like to first ask people how
did you end up
studying grading in grades what was your
path to get here yeah that's that's a
really fun question and one i'm really
excited and passionate about um i don't
think i went into education i don't
think anyone really went into education
to get better at grading in fact it
might just be something that we
all have to do although in 2008 i was a
high school math teacher here in iowa i
went to the state math teacher
conference and there was a breakout
session it was called how to fix your
broken grade book led by another high
school math teacher i thought well i'll
just go and see if i can take something
away back to my own classroom and get a
little bit better
kristin literally that 45 to 50 minute
session changed my professional career
forever i came back really excited
talked to our high school principal at
the time and
just you know thanked him for allowing
me to go back in
in 2008 and
he just really encouraged me to say hey
could you try out something that you
learned from this session in your
classroom i thought well there's only
nine weeks left in the school year that
seems kind of crazy but i picked my last
period geometry class and just started
changing some things up related to
grading and as a result of that i
started reading every book or article or
blog post i could find about grading
fast forward a couple years later i had
a number of conversations with other
teachers in our in our high school in
our middle school and they started
thinking differently about grading fast
forward another year or so later and i
got promoted to the district office and
we had this
dilemma in our school in in in solon
iowa this this little rural community in
iowa where some of our teachers were
thinking differently about grading and
others weren't yet and so we had a
decision to make were we going to kind
of be okay with that middle ground
or we were going to go on a journey to
see if we all wanted to think about
grading differently so obviously we made
that decision to all think about grading
differently and so my experience comes
from being a classroom teacher doing
this standards-based grading thing and
also
leading a change in our school district
to make grading practices significantly
different you mentioned our books making
grades matter and again as a high school
math teacher i don't really consider
myself to be an author or really that
great of a writer but uh through others
that have written books and heard about
our work we're actually encouraged to
write our own book and so
in standards-based incentives-based
grading it's not always viewed as
something that is easily attainable at
the secondary level in particular
um and so our book really helps uh
middle school and high school teachers
um take their next steps with
standards-based grading so that's a
little bit about my journey currently
though i work at the university of
northern iowa where i teach future
principals and superintendents and also
uh support as many educators as possible
uh to take their next steps towards more
effective grading practices and it's
just a thrill to be here today talk
about a topic i'm really really really
passionate about
that is great so let's start at the
beginning
what is standards-based grading
yeah great
maybe the best way to explain it is um
it's it's a it's a philosophy or a
process
or a set of practices that really aim
to communicate students current levels
of learning separately
from their behaviors
when you think about maybe the grading
practices that you and i experienced as
a student maybe we got like a a 95 in a
class
but that 95 could have mean we got
95 percent of the points or it could
have meant we actually got 100 of the
points and turned in a couple
assignments late and so
maybe in the past we've mixed kind of
behaviors with with learning
in standards-based grading those two
things are are separate
and
i think about when i take my car
to a mechanic sometimes i do a 20-point
inspection and on that 20-point
inspection it tells me if my brakes are
really good or not very good if my
battery is really good or not very good
and so mechanic kind of breaks down the
components of my vehicle and gives me
very specific feedback on how well my
car is doing in each one of those and so
that's the aim of standards-based
grading is really just to give our
students a much more detailed
perspective on a standard by standard
basis if you will on what they're doing
really well at and what they could get
even better at
and also embeds elements of probably
something i know you're very passionate
about uh mastery learning as well and i
hope we can talk more about that today
that's great so
from a student perspective what are the
benefits of grading this way as opposed
to a more traditional way yeah so so
maybe in the past students have found
themselves not really knowing what the
currency of the classroom is sometimes
it's just all about earning
when they're at that cusp of uh
89.4 percent and they want to get their
grade up to an 89.5 percent so they'll
get rounded up to the favorable grade
they want to get the scholarship or the
honor roll or the gpa that they want
they may just ask the teacher what can i
do to improve my grade and maybe the
teacher is in a good mood that day and
says here's a extra credit crossword
puzzle or here's something else you can
do
but maybe the teacher is not in that
great of a mood or just maybe has more
of a hey you need to you know just do
better next time mindset
because the currency the classroom is
all about earning at that at that point
when the currency of the classroom which
is what standards-based grading is all
about is more about learning
now a student might ask hey mr townsley
i'm not very good yet at pythagorean's
theorem could i show you
how i'm better at pythagorean's theorem
now
and by showing me as the teacher that
they're actually better at pythagorean's
theorem then as a result of that their
grade might improve which is a good
thing right because the student has
learned more of the math stuff or the
science stuff or the social studies
stuff
they should of course have a better
grade because the purpose of grades is
really to communicate students current
levels of learning so students really i
believe are more
uh they have more ownership
in their in the learning process because
it's it's more about what's what they're
in control of which is the extent to
which they've learned the standards in
the class
got it so i see that link so as we think
about mastery learning here one of the
things that we're thinking about is that
you're doing what whatever the work you
need is to increase your proficiency or
work towards mastery and it's not that
you get one shot at a test and that's
your score but you can keep learning and
keep trying and improving on that over
time does that fit in then to this idea
of
grading based on standards yes indeed it
does and in my own research i've uh read
quite a bit about master learning so i
can confirm this on a on that level
kristin uh as i think back to master
learning i think of benjamin bloom and
others that have really set the
foundation for what mastery learning is
and you know back in the day there was
this mentality of well only a certain
percent of the students ought to deserve
an a or only a certain element of
students ought to be successful in a
class kind of that bell-shaped curve
iq testing mentality
but when blue and others really
challenged that mindset they said you
know what
if we provide students more time and the
right conditions
many many many many more students can
learn at a high level in other words if
if achievement can be constant
and time can become the variable
then even more students can learn at a
high level
and as i think about standards-based
grading that's really what it aims to do
as i think about the grading practices
again that maybe you and i experienced
back in the day kristin if we did not do
very well kind of early on in the
learning process maybe we you know turn
in some homework assignments that we
didn't really understand what was going
on in class we kind of dug ourselves
into a whole point wise or
percentage-wise
within a standards-based grading mindset
it's really all about how much has a
student learned and if
kristen if you or i and i are in the
same class and you may be learning
before i do
one of the premises of of
standards-based grading is it doesn't
really matter when a student learns it
we honor the fact that students learn at
different rates in different paces
and if my learning comes later i'm going
to erase that old version of learning in
the gradebook and replace it with more
recent evidence of learning and again
that's a maybe a mindset shift in
particular for uh for many of our
secondary educators out there but it
really comes it's not necessarily a new
idea it comes from years and years and
years of theory and research related to
mastery learning
i think leann lee and young and tom
guskey in their 2011 article in the
clearinghouse really made some strong
connections between mastery learning and
also the response to intervention model
that many schools are working towards
right now that just says hey you know
what if we can really provide quality
instruction if we can also then provide
the right amount of interventions to
students who still do not understand it
we can help a lot of students learn at a
high level and all of those things
really fit in the standards-based
grading and master learning bucket if
you will
that totally makes sense and this also
is reminding me of links to
motivation research where there's
whether students are motivated about to
learn or whether they're motivated to
get a score that shows what they learn
and then students who are motivated
based on learning a new thing tend to be
more engaged and more interested in
learning is that connected to all this
as well in terms of increasing student
motivation
of course yes again as i think about the
default feedback that i included that i
gave to students back in the day before
i went to this state math teacher
conference
i would frequently give students like a
14 out of 16 on a quiz but that 14 of 16
really didn't tell the student what
they're doing really well at and what
they need to get better at i mean
imagine if i went to the doctor's office
the doctor's office said you're you know
you're about at 85 health i'd be like
well what's the other 15 doc like tell
me tell me tell me and so at the heart
of standards-based grading is using uh
some other type of scale you know many
uh schools we use like uh an almost uh
or a proficient or some other descriptor
of learning
to tell a student exactly the extent to
which they have learned that particular
standard and really what it is it's it's
much more specific feedback to the
student on exactly what they're doing
and what they need to do to get better
one of the things that i look back on my
own teaching career and wonder is how
often was i giving feedback to students
that really helped them understand how
to close the gap uh and so sometimes
when when educators start doing this
standards-based grading thing they
realize that it's not just the gradebook
that needs to improve but it's also
their feedback practices
and
you know if i can just give a shout out
to so many wonderful researchers and
authors out there uh susan brookhart
dylan william and others that really
talked about uh feedback being at the
heart of the learning process
and our students really deserve feedback
not on a unit 3 test or in just an essay
perspective but on a much more granular
level on a standard by standard level
and we provide them that very detailed
level of feedback you're right kristin
the research suggests they're much more
excited motivated to improve upon that
feedback
that makes sense so
you said this could be a change in
thinking and mindset for some educators
and where things are what are some
things that for instance when you came
back from this this conference or what
are maybe some initial steps that
teachers can take towards this uh this
different mindset
yeah a couple things
one is in my mind i tend to think about
you know uh
textbooks and chapters as being the
driving force for what i taught in fact
i'll never forget when i got my first
teaching job i was assigned to teach
geometry and several courses and i asked
some of their teachers and said hey like
what are kids supposed to learn geometry
and they said well here's the textbook
most years we get to chapter 12 and some
years we get to chapter 13 like here you
go
and so of course that's what i did
but now what i know is you know most
states have uh some list of state
standards right like there have been
some some some people have gotten
together and said these are the most
important things that students are
supposed to learn in biology or algebra
1 or 7th grade science and so instead of
thinking about the textbook being the
driving force and what we teach we
should look at the standards
i worked with some pe teachers even in
our school district and they said well i
was just so used to always doing you
know the volleyball unit or the pe uh or
the football unit and and
and frankly like that's the way they've
always done it and so
that's okay but we started thinking
about what are the specific learning
goals what are the specific standards
that students are supposed to be
learning in pe or seventh grade science
or math and so instead of thinking about
the activities and the units as being
the driver we have to first start
thinking about the standards or the
learning goals being the driver and then
secondly we have to design assessments
that are very well aligned to those
learning goals or those standards again
so many of us we just inherited uh the
assessments right the
the tests that come with the with the
textbook materials or or the the the
tests or the quizzes or the projects
that have been handed down from one
teacher to the next
we have to ask ourselves to what extent
are those actually aligned to the
learning goals that we want
and then finally
if
if i'm thinking about just the typical
high school or middle school teacher so
many of us are used to grading based
upon points and percentages
and points and percentages don't really
do the best job of communicating to
students
what they're really good at and what
they're not really good at i mean think
about this what's the difference between
a student who has 96 percent on a test
and 94 on a test is there is there some
like really is there a difference that's
actually
describable
can we put our mind and our hands and
our in our in our fingers on what that
difference is in the in that two percent
so
when educators really wrap their mind
around the standards-based grading thing
they're going to instead of thinking
about percentages they're going to think
about some levels of learning uh like
beginning developing area of concern and
proficient
and again that's just a huge mind shift
for for so many of us not because
we may not want to do it but because in
our teacher preparation programs we
haven't necessarily been taught how to
do it yet
and i'm confident as we continue to
improve and evolve in uh in our teacher
preparation and administrative
preparation programs that in time will
get to that point where more educators
will be familiar with this process
yeah so that leads me to think how much
can
can a teacher do this on their own
versus how much do they need the school
support changing what the report cards
look like changing what you know the the
parents are expecting to come home and
where those are what's the the balance
between those
oh christian you're giving me some good
flashbacks to uh 2008 2009 as is myself
and just a few other teachers as we
started doing it frankly christian it
was a it was an uphill battle for for a
number of years because in our
classrooms we were trying to re-culture
as i referred to earlier as as the
currency of our classroom for students
being all about learning
uh and and again this is not because
the other teachers from our school were
consciously doing it but that's just
because that's just what they knew and
so
students in my class might have i might
have been the only teacher that they had
all day long where the currency of the
classroom was
learning early on and so it takes a
really passionate knowledgeable teacher
to say you know what there's going to be
some some hiccups there are going to be
some implementation dips along the way
and one very specific one as we think
about again this idea of mastery
learning
is that time becomes the variable
not the constant
we want achievement to be the constant
so myself as a teacher i have to figure
out times during my class period or
times during the school day where i can
provide additional instruction to
students who have not yet demonstrated
understanding of pythagorean's theorem
or the other standards in the classroom
and that's much easier when the whole
school is on board you know we'll hear
about schools doing an intervention time
or a what i need time or if their mascot
is tiger a tiger time where school-wide
students are provided time
for additional instruction and
reassessments
if those specific times during the day
are not in place
and if the culture of most classrooms is
still more about earning than is about
learning for individual teachers this is
going to be a
uh
a pretty big uphill battle
and so that's why in our book making
grades matter we talk about the the
individual classroom shifts in in many
of our chapters and we talk about doing
it as a as a team as a professional
learning community together
and then the final chapter of our book
we also talk about uh specifically how
to make this entire shift as a school
and so in the research that i've done
and then i've seen kristin uh almost
always there is a certain level of an
implementation dip that happens
and it's most often because uh we're not
approaching it as an entire school and
understanding that there will be an
implementation dip and so i appreciate
that question so i want to encourage uh
listeners and viewers out there that are
really thinking about making the shifts
to to know and appreciate the
implementation dip and and to write it
out and to encourage uh our entire
school uh to make these changes in in
time and it really does take time
that totally makes sense so we have a
couple questions that are similar uh to
each other and along the same line so
one from aviv and one from lance
mcconnell so
what are the the things to to start to
work with teachers to help shift
mindsets and aviva asked if teachers
have less flexibility what are some
things that they can do again a first
couple of steps to start changing their
practice
yeah i'd say a couple things
one is just to first take a kind of a
balcony view and say what's the purpose
of grades in my classroom you know
sometimes we'll we'll kind of jump right
down to the actionable things that the
teachers should do and like maybe
instead of giving zeros for incomplete
work maybe just give 50s sometimes we'll
hear about schools doing that and while
that's an admirable practice
in absence of really focusing on what's
the purpose of grades oh the purpose of
grades is to communicate learning so
just having the conversation with a
department having a conversation with
individual teacher having a conversation
at a faculty meeting like what do we
believe as a school or as a team as the
purpose of grading
and then if while we're waiting for
maybe everyone's to move forward in an
actionable way and some of the things i
mentioned earlier
individual teachers can start doing what
i call having one fit one foot in the
standards-based grading world and one
foot in the traditional grading world
and we can experiment with our students
for example at an upcoming uh test
um if you know as a teacher that you
cannot yet put like a one two three or
four or a
area of concern beginning
almost there proficient in the grade
book yet you could still provide that
same level of feedback to students
on an upcoming test for each standard or
learning goal
and just ask students hey if with this
level of feedback what do you want to do
next how can i help you as a teacher
improve on these learning goals what can
you do as a student to improve on these
learning goals and you can have the
conversation without having to change
anything at all in the gradebook now
in that scenario you would still put
whatever the the building or the
district requires like a percentage in
the gradebook but you would have the
conversation with your students to see
how they would react to a much more
specific
learning goal feedback and i think what
most educators will find is that
students actually crave that same level
of feedback
one of the things i did in my own
classroom is i started asking students
about the level of feedback they got
from their
their drama director or their musical
director or their band instructor or
their football coach and most often all
of those extracurricular or
co-curricular sponsors and coaches
gave them very detailed feedback and so
i think if we make that connection even
if we can't be all in in the grade book
because of building or district policy
constraints we can still begin to
provide that same level of feedback to
our students
and see how they react to it
and what that's going to require is just
taking a more precise look at our
assessments and aligning the standards
and i think any teacher can start doing
that you know now
without having to have the permission of
their administration or have some switch
turned on at the electronic gradebook
level to make that possible
great
here's another question from facebook
greg mullin
it's a little bit different but
interesting how
how does standards-based grading help
prepare students for higher education
and i wonder if there's a sub-question
in there of like if i have good grades
like this are colleges going to look at
it kind of funny
yeah fun fun to hear some of these uh
names thrown out there kristen thank you
lance thank you greg for your questions
uh regarding your question here greg um
just a fantastic question one that is
very important to discuss specifically
for high schools making this shift uh
first so often
secondary parents or secondary teachers
or secondary administrators will say if
we do this is it really going to prepare
students for college
first a couple things first if
most of the high schools i know that do
this they still eventually determine a
specific letter grade
from the standard marks in the grade
book and so these high schools still
have a gpa that's still used for
admissions and scholarship decisions
now down the weeds a little bit then a
next
question maybe greg's thinking about is
but what if we provide students these
multiple opportunities what what if we
provide these redos and retakes in the
spirit of mastery learning they may or
may not do that at the college level
well
what we have to know at the at the k-12
level is our aim
because of federal legislation such as
no child left behind and every student
succeeds act our aim is to help as many
kids as possible get it like that's our
job in the k-12 world that may or may
not be what the university and college
folks are are doing and again as a
college professor i can kind of speak to
that that there's just a different
paradigm sometimes at the college
university level so regardless of what
college or universities do
our aim in k-12 is to help as many kids
as possible get it and so we believe
that kids learn at different rates in
different paces
so we're of course that it makes sense
to provide students multiple
opportunities to demonstrate their
learning through this whole reteaching
and reassessment process
and finally
some research that i've done with dr
thomas gusky and dr thomas buckmiller
suggests that college students
at the end of their first semester
freshman year we actually went through
some surveys and interviews of students
who self-disclosed that they went to a
high school that was doing this
standards-based grading stuff
they shared with us in our research that
was published towards the end of 2020 in
the nassp bulletin journal that they had
just uh an okay time adjusting to the
college and university level and so if
we have this idea in our mind that's
somehow going to wreck them as they
transition to the college university
our research suggests that's just not
the case
um as well so thank you greg and others
for that wonderful wonderful question
excellent lots of good questions coming
in um here's a another one thinking
about um
how does this apply
to gifted students
um fantastic and i wonder if there's
thoughts about yeah does this create a
ceiling that you know that prevents
gifted students from maybe moving into
accelerated work or something
i think there's two facets that are
actually beneficial uh to to gifted
education uh one of them is this i mean
i think about some students i had my own
classroom uh that were they were just
high achievers and and i worked in a
high achieving school district one of
the most high achieving school districts
in the state of iowa and there were some
students who they were still required
you know this was pre-standards-based
grading they were still required to do
the homework or the practice because
there was a point value attached to it
but they they knew their parents knew i
knew that they really didn't need to do
that practice and so it was just busy
work for the sake of getting points to
get the grade they wanted in a
standards-based grading uh
philosophy or school um there is no
point value attached to home to
assignments that are intended to be more
practice oriented so if i'm a gifted
student now i no longer am
subjected to doing busy work for the
sake of busy work to get points i think
that's a huge win for our gifted
students who may have other aspirations
uh secondly in in some schools what they
will do is they'll say wow
this student based upon this assessment
evidence i have right now is already
proficient they're already rocking and
rolling
with a specific standard and so i'm
going to provide some level of extension
activity
for the student before we would not have
had that same detailed level of
information for the learner
because prior to standards-based grading
we would not have known by the student
by the standard who was already getting
it
but with a standards-based grading
mentality and gradebook now we'll know
specifically not just who the gifted
students are but the specific standards
that they're absolutely rocking and
rolling with so
kristen i think to summarize this this
standards-based grading thing can be
very beneficial to to gifted uh students
or or the high-achieving students
because it provides better information
to them
and to their teachers about where it is
exactly they're rocking and rolling and
it frankly just eliminates some busy
work that they may have been subjected
to
in the past
great all right i'm gonna i'm gonna
sneak in one more question here
before we close out so the other place
that i've been hearing a lot about
standard standards-based grading it's in
conversations around equity and in
schools that are serving students from
historically under-resourced communities
tell me how you see standards-based
grading potentially helping those
students
yeah there's plenty of research that has
been done about the factors that
teachers consider
in in determining a grade and this is
again pre-standards-based grading and
what we'll find in that research is that
often teachers consider things like
participation
sometimes even attendance and what we
know when we look at students of
of different backgrounds
is that
by grading based upon participation in
tenants that is a very inequitable
practice
for some student groups
i also think about just to focus in on a
very specific practice that i'm ashamed
to say that i did in my own classroom
that's awarding extra credit points for
students bringing in materials such as
kleenex boxes or whiteboard markers
think about the families that are able
to do that in the families that are not
able to do that it's pretty obvious
that there are families who are able to
to buy their kids grades or improve
their kids grades by bringing in these
materials i think of course this is just
a far out over exaggerated example but
this happens
to the point where there was a
legislator in iowa several years ago
that proposed a law to eliminate this
practice because of
the very question that you brought up
kristen so perhaps the viewers and
listeners here that are thinking about
maybe just a real small step they
consider if we are to eliminate
the awarding of extra credit for
materials that's one step closer to more
equitable grading practices and if we
want to eliminate providing some points
in our classrooms for participation
or or for attendance
that would be another great and
wonderful step we could do
that is more equitable for students of
different backgrounds and demographics
so yeah and just give a shout out to joe
feldman who wrote a fantastic book
called grading for equity that speaks
even more detail to this very topic and
so we're hearing some pretty big school
districts across the state saying we
want to make some of these grading
changes because equity is our driving
force behind it and i i'm saddened to
see that the coven 19 happened
but in a way i'm pretty excited to know
that as a result of cobin 19 happening
that more schools are recognizing how to
create and utilize more equitable
grading practices so thank you for
bringing that topic to light kristin
absolutely well this 30 minutes has
flown by it's been so nice talking to
you thank you for all the research
you're doing and the work you're doing
to help schools and teachers make this
shift it's been a pleasure talking to
you today
thank you very much kristen for having
me it's been it's been a pleasure
great and thanks for everyone out there
who's been listening we will see you
next time
you